fascismo
a partir de hoy gustavo petro se vuelve
el nuevo inquilino de la casa de nariño
para los próximos cuatro años originario
del departamento de córdoba creció y se
inició como sindicalista durante su
adolescencia en zipaquirá
a los 17 años se hizo militante de la
guerrilla m-19 y el conocido como
comandante aureliano por la novela a 100
años de soledad no dejó las armas y
firmó la paz hasta 1990 momento desde el
que la defiende como parte de su
programa político
construir la paz
como decíamos venía celebrando
metido en la política desde que salió de
la guerrilla en 2006 fue elegido como el
senador con la tercera votación más alta
de la historia del país en 2011 se
convirtió en el alcalde de bogotá con
más del 32 por ciento de los votos pero
su mandato terminó abruptamente con una
revocatoria en su contra entre otros
motivos por la gestión del sistema de
basuras de bogotá
el alcalde mayor de bogotá
independientemente quién se solo puede
ser destituido por causas taxativas
escritas en la ley por el presidente la
república hablaba que un golpe de estado
con dos intentos fracasados de conseguir
la presidencia del país en 2010 y 2018
respectivamente pedro ha mantenido su
política centrada en la lucha contra la
pobreza la desigualdad y la corrupción
en el país
los colombianos no tenemos en nuestros
genes la violencia los y las colombianas
lo que no hemos podido es tener
oportunidades
y ahora con sus políticas sociales a
favor del paro nacional del 2021 el
político representa un desafío a la
sucesión de gobiernos de derecha que han
ocupado el poder en colombia
históricamente
29 de mayo
es el grito de la libertad en colombia
porque the record de rock haremos el
régimen de corrupción porque cambiaremos
la historia porque abriremos las sendas
para que podamos convivir en paz ahora
petro tiene cuatro años para demostrar
que su propuesta de cambio es la mejor
opción para colombia